hello
welcome to our 2021 lab root series
sponsored by thermo fisher scientific
my name is leia lavery a marketing
manager for life science electron
microscopy
and your moderator today this is the
second webinar in our series
and we welcome back any returning
attendees and a big hello
to any new attendees wherever you are in
the world many of you know
thermo fisher from other life science
areas but i want to introduce you to the
life science electron microscopy
division
our materials and structural analysis
division provides complete workloads
from cryo-electron microscopy structural
determination
of macromolecular complexes in native
states to 3d reconstruction of tissues
and cells
last year we broke the atomic resolution
crayon barrier with the
director of this electric imaging filter
with 300 kv cryo
tm today we will be discussing what's
possible
with the energy filtering for 300 kv and
also 200 kv
cryo tm and several examples we will
highlight discoveries of what's now
possible to look at
underlying protein function and cellular
processes with this electric imaging
filter
today's presentation is titled
cryo-electron microscopy
membrane proteins down to atoms it will
be given by my colleagues mark storms
and abhai crotasia
and our special guest speaker professor
stephen ohan from
uc berkeley after today's presentation
there will be a question and answer
session
please submit your question at any time
through the q a window
let me now introduce my colleague mark
storms product marketing manager to
start us off
so welcome everybody to this uh thermal
feature
uh uc berkeley webinar thank you once
more leah for introducing us
um i'm very excited today to show you
again
uh some some new data and new
developments actually that we have uh
been working on
the last couple of months or years
actually um
and while showing this this video of the
cryo c4 you can very nicely see the
interior
of the system and what is really inside
the cryos and also the components that
we talk
about today and i will shortly recap are
all inside this this box as you
as you know
so for those who have been listening
before to this webinar
cycle we have me discussing a lot of new
innovations
uh recently actually actually the last
couple of years already
first of all as a short recap of course
we have the crying sg4 you already saw
the animation on the previous slide and
of course we also have the glacials
i think both tools are famous for their
uh significantly reduced
height which makes it relatively easy to
install the systems in the standard lap
room without too
significant rumor innovation efforts
basically
with respect to both platforms we've
also implemented
a significant automation not only
automation in order to get to the right
optical status before you start doing
experiments
the so-called apm or advanced
performance monitoring
but also automation in the application
software for example epu
which makes it easier to facilitate for
example the screening
of grids and last but at least of course
we have been pushing the productivity
by implementing at least with respect to
the platforms aberration free image
shifting and french free imaging as you
as you all know
um the second actually branch to the
tree if you like
uh was introduced last year the
selectris
which actually is uh yeah our newly
designed and developed
energy filter it's very famous for its
stability i will spend on the next slide
a little bit more time on this
um it's also actually very easy to use
in terms of setting up the experiments
um and in case actually there would be
some
uh tuning needed because of course there
is always actually some alignment needed
and this is actually going to happen uh
very easily
and then very uh yeah easily because it
has been implemented this process into
our
application so for epu and tomography
but i'll get back to that on the next
slide with a little bit more details
especially when we talk about
stability and then the the third
component which is of course also an
integral part of the selectors
but it can also be used of course
standalone is the falcon 4 camera
uh we have significantly boosted the
speed of the falcon 4 camera but in
addition to that we have also
pushed the dqe the sensitivity across
the entire full frequency range
for those doses that are typically used
for cryotomography
and single particle analysis but last
but not least we have also implemented
this
nice feature called electron defense
representation which actually is a
clever
way to do more efficient lossless data
compression
but still while still benefiting from
the full temporal
and spatial resolutions so we can also
actually enable
because of this pixel accuracy
capability the super resolution
capabilities of the camera
and i'm pleased actually to announce the
fourth addition
to this combination that's why we talk
about the power of four actually in this
presentation
and that's our um colfac um our callback
which we call
easy fact the e stands for energy spread
because we've optimized the energy
spreads performance
of the goldfag and as i will show you
also in the next couple of slides
this colfax enables to get higher
contrast
push resolutions especially beyond the
two angstrom level
and it also gives us a possibility and
gives you the possibility
to actually achieve resolutions in a
shorter
time frame
but first a little bit again some extra
information with respect to the
selectors already mentioned that this is
actually a very
stable energy filter in terms of the the
zero loss position
and behavior over a longer period of
time which of course is important if you
want to do
long and during experiments and in these
two graphs you show actually the actual
measured performance of the selector
stability on the cricus and on the
glacials
and you see that that the behavior the
measured behavior
of the cellulose position is very well
within our specification of
plus and minus 1.5 electron volts it's a
measure of a period of 24 hours
in fact it's more close to to plus or
minus 1 ev
in reality uh so it's extremely stable
and the small
periodic periodicities that you see here
in in the as a small dip actually in
this measurement are related to the
autofilling of the liquid nitrogen
as i mentioned it's actually a very
stable filter so the
in case you have to do some some
frequent centering and tuning
it happens uh yeah invisible because
it's been fully integrated into our
application software
and the uh the fully automated filter
alignments
uh are also done relatively fast within
less than five minutes you've really
done it
the most actually you have practical
value again
is the fact that we have this very
stable energy slit and
that basically is a key enabler for very
exciting
uh scientific results that will be
discussed by stephen and abbay
later in this presentation
and that brings me to the to the kolfac
as i mentioned
before that our new coalfact is
optimized for low energy spread that's
what the e stands for
the ec fact or energy spread
optimized colfag and as you can see in
this graph where we have been
comparing the uh the colfac
behavior versus the classical extract
behavior
then you can really see that the energy
spread has significantly been approved
uh our official specification here is
less than 0.3
electron volts compared to the x factor
high brightness effect which was
actually the standard effect on on
or cryos and glacials that has an energy
spread of 0.7 ev
and the advantage obviously of having
this this better
energy spread behavior is what you can
see back if you look to the contrast
transfer function and you see that
especially at the high
spatial frequency range there is a much
stronger contrast signal
when you talk about actually the lower
energy spread
behavior and that of course translate
back
into a higher resolution capabilities
and obvi and stephen will actually talk
about that
in this in their presentation parts and
also because of the better contrast
behavior
you can reach actually higher
resolutions in the shorter possible time
with respect to the other specifications
uh like the brightness they are similar
to what
with the extract specifications also we
have a very high brightness actually but
simultaneously
we have a very low uh energy spread
performance um spot revolves the same
specification
as for the years for the x-pac in this
case and the
irregular flashings or the regular
flashing actually intervals
that you have to do every once in a
while it's also something that doesn't
disturb your experimental
performance because it's fully automated
and batting into our epu and tomography
software so you will not be actually
uh bothered by any of these
interruptions with respect to your
experiments
and last but not least um yeah our
colfac actually has a five-year standard
warranty
to actually show the confidence that we
have in the in the product
and with that introduction on what we
call the power of four i would really
like to
to show you and introduce you to uh to
stephen brohan the first uh
speaker and up i will follow up um who
will talk about
what you can really do with the
combination of these powerful
instruments
um a short introduction stephen actually
is an assistant professor
of neurobiology at the university of
california in
in berkeley at the department of
molecular cell biology
um and the helen world's neuroscience
institute um
there are institutes basically focusing
and also his work is on understanding
the basis of sensory transduction
and electrical signaling of the of the
nervous system
and to this end actually his lab is
using cryo-electron microscopy as a
major tool to investigate a
structure-functioning relationship with
membrane
proteins and also ion channels important
to mention is that
dr braun is a new york stem cell
foundation
robertson neuroscience investigator and
his work has been recognized
by many and many occasions already for
example with the sloan research
fellowship
mcknight neuroscience school of awards
and the kligenstein simon
uh siemens research fellowship so we
actually were very happy
to have steven here today in our webinar
series
so i'll give the floor to you stephen
okay thank you very much leah and mark
for the introduction
and the invitation to be here today i'm
excited to tell you about
two short stories from my lab about
improvements and resolution of the
structures of small membrane proteins
using the instrumentation that we're
discussing here today and
the uh best of these reconstructions is
shown in the background of this side
here at 22.1 angstrom resolution
so the first of these stories concerns a
protein
called orf3a this is a putative viral
ion channel encoded by the sars covi2
genome we became interested in this
protein at the beginning of the pandemic
last year
as a potential alternative target for
vaccine or therapeutic development
based on work that had been done in the
related sars cov1
and were also interested in this protein
because it appeared to represent a novel
membrane protein ion channel fold
and so this is a very small protein at
31 kilodaltons
as a monomer and so was a challenging
target for
cryo-em but a fantastic postdoc in my
lab david kern
was able to in just a few short months
develop an expression purification
system
reconstitute dimeric 3a into lipid
nanodiscs
and on instrumentation here at uc
berkeley collect data
and determine the structure of this
protein the 2.9 angstrom resolution
and the local resolution of the final
map is shown
on the right of the slide here so i'd
just like to acknowledge
jonathan remus and dan taso at the uc
berkeley cal cryo facility for coming in
at a tough time in the pandemic to
collect these data and chris hull a
graduate student in my lab who worked
with david to process
the data and generate this
reconstruction and so we were um able to
learn
quite a bit from this a really rather
high resolution map for such a small
membrane protein and posted a preprint
in june of last year describing the
results
but we were even more excited to have
the opportunity to collaborate with abe
kotecha therma fisher to see if we could
use this new uh microscope hardware to
push the resolution of this
reconstruction
um even further and so we took the grids
out of the arctica that we collected the
first data set on
they've crossed his fingers and shipped
them to the netherlands where
albe was able to collect the data data
set for us
and and that's shown here and indeed
from these data we were
in fact able to improve the resolution
of this reconstruction
um substantially to 2.1 angstrom
resolution
and so this is using the titan creos
with cold sag and selectors x
energy filter and falcon 4 camera
so you can see immediately i think the
improvement in map quality
from the image shown on this slide and
i'll just show the two maps next to one
another so
that the comparison is more clear it's
really substantially more detail
in this higher resolution map on the
right
i put this table here just to emphasize
that
these data were collected similarly in
fact it's a smaller data set
in the higher resolution that led to the
higher resolution reconstruction
about half as many final particles and i
also wanted to point out that all these
data are publicly available
the raw movies the maps and the models
are all deposited
and we were excited to see both the emdb
and the ku software package use these
data
in their recent modeling challenges
so we were able to do four additional
things in this higher resolution map
compared to our first reconstruction
first we were able to model a portion
of the membrane scaffold proteins
msp1e3d1 protein
in this kind of tan color on on the map
on the left here
second we were able to correctly model
a large number of side chain rotameric
positions that were
ambiguous in the 2.9 angstrom map
but clearly defined in the higher
resolution reconstruction
third we were able to model
approximately 120 ordered water
molecules which are shown in blue
and the map the model here and
fourth we were able to model two
specifically bound lipid molecules
inside the 3a
central cavity
so we see that 3a adopts a novel fold
here
with three transmembrane helices um
and a cytoplasmic beta sandwich domain
that
assembled tightly into it into a dimer
and as we were thinking about the
putative function
of this protein as an ion channel
we observe
that 3a adopts a structure in which it
has a large
inner cavities that's polar that's
connected to the cytoplasm
and the surrounding membrane through
three pairs of water and lipid filled
tunnels
and i'll show you those in a little more
detail here
so the first
set of these tunnels is shown on the
left in the slice throughs
of the surface of the protein
there's a upper tunnel hair of upper
tunnels which we speculated
were connected to the surrounding lipid
bilayer and indeed
in these tunnels we don't see evidence
of bound
water molecules ordered water molecules
there are a pair of lower tunnels that
are
we speculated we're connected to the
cytoplasmic solution and in fact these
tunnels were lined with ordered water
molecules consistent with that
idea and on the other side of the slide
here you can see
a third pair of tunnels these
inter-subunit tunnels that had
density in the 2.9 angstrom resolution
reconstruction
that was difficult to model
not really interpretable but in the
higher resolution reconstruction we can
see very clearly that these
densities correspond to ordered lipid
molecules that are bound inside the
channel cavity and we model these as a
pair of dope
lipids with the ethanolamine head group
of the lipid
pointed inside the channel cavity making
interactions with very conserved
residues within 3a
and so this improvement of resolution
has helped us think about how this
protein might function
in in the viral life cycle as an ion
channel
by adopting this fold in which a large
polar cavity is connected to the
cytoplasmic solution through these lower
tunnels
in which ions can can freely pass and
then potentially traverse to the other
side of the membrane through a central
pore
that's closed in this structure or a
long
partially exposed hydrophilic grooves on
the outside
of the protein okay
and so the second story that i'd like to
tell you about
um is the following
concerns a ion channel
called tas2 it's a potassium selective
channel in eukaryotes
that's ph regulated and it's one of the
conserved functions
is in the regulation of breathing
where tasty senses ph changes that are
correlated to
changes in the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the blood
to um determine
the firing rate of nuclei of
retrotrapezoid nucleus neurons that
instruct
respiration muscles and determine the
rate
of breathing so this is another small
membrane protein this is about
60 kilodaltons of ordered membrane
protein
this is a two poor domain family ion
channel
in which two of these canonical
potassium channel poor domains are
concatenated into a single chain
and so we were interested in
understanding how
protons regulate the activity of this
channel and
uh set out to determine its structure
this is work of another fantastic
postdoc in my lab
alvin lee who's currently on the job
market
in collaboration with a graduate student
robert reedmeyer
in my group and so valvon was able to
purify task two
reconstitute it into lipid nanodiscs and
determine
its structure at three and a half
angstrom resolution
using data collected again with dan and
john
here uc berkeley on our arctica
microscope
and so this structure and another
structure at a lower ph
allowed us to understand new aspects of
how this channel is regulated by protons
and so dalvin and robert found
that task 2 exhibits two new kinds of
channel gate
from these two structures both at around
three and a half angstrom resolution
one of these gates is near the
extracellular aspect of the channel
and involves conformational changes to
the selectivity filter
which forms potassium coordination sites
that determine the selectivity of this
channel for potassium
the second gate is at the intracellular
aspect of the channel
and involves a rearrangement that
pinches this
region of the channel shut
so similarly we were interested in
whether we could
understand more about how this channel
operates
from higher resolution structures and so
bowden
in an analogous way took the grids out
of our arctica that we didn't collect on
shipped them to the netherlands and abe
was able to collect a data set for us
and these data led to a reconstruction
that was again improved substantially
from our
initial reconstructions this one to two
and a half angstrom resolution
and i'm showing the final map here on
the right of this slide
and i just wanted to point out two
aspects that we were able to model
um that we were not able to model in the
lower resolution reconstruction the
first is
again portions of these membrane
scaffold proteins that form the belt
around the lipid nanodisc and in this
case
similar to the case of 3a make some
specific interactions
with residues and transmembrane helices
on the channel
and the second aspect are a number of
ordered
lipid molecules several of which i've
pointed out here
and i'd like to draw your attention to
one of these lipid
molecules that we can see in the higher
resolution
map and that i've colored in red on this
slide here
i'm going to show you a view from the
cytoplasmic aspect of the channel
up towards this lipid to illustrate why
we find this particular lipid very
interesting
functionally and so this lipid as it
turns out
is bound inside the channel cavity
through that kind of lateral membrane
opening
and in this position it sits directly
underneath
of the potassium selectivity filter and
in this position it would
appear to block conduction and we find
this
really quite fascinating because there
is evidence
from our work on related channels that
this may be a conserved
means of regulating channel activity in
this family
by having lipid block lion conduction
in this conformation in which lateral
membrane openings are exposed
and so what we can see in this slide
here is that from the lower resolution
reconstructions we were able to
understand
how protons are sensed
on the extracellular and intracellular
sides of the channel
to get the channel closed with the
selectivity filter and inner gate
respectively
and we're now very interested in
understanding how this potential lipid
block
of ion conduction works in these
channels and how it
interacts with these other proton gates
on either side of the membrane and so
with that
i would like to acknowledge my lab
and again just point out that the
microscopy that i talked about was done
by david kern with help chris hole
and and balcony and i would like to
acknowledge my funding sources
and collaborators especially um ave
cateche
thermo fisher dan tasso and john remus
here at
our cal cryo yum facility um diana
bautista and her graduate students malay
molly
and halela desnik and his postdoc
sabitha schrodharen
who are collaborators on the 3a project
for functional work that i didn't talk
about
so thank you very much
thank you steve for this wonderful talk
it's really amazing to see because
uh just few years ago um talking about
such sub 100 kilo kilodalton proteins
and cryo em
was very difficult to imagine and now
you showed
uh that we can not only work on such
proteins
these proteins were very flexible uh and
also very heterogeneous
and yet you can get such high resolution
this just shows that how how quickly and
how such a short time
technology has come together which
allows you to answer
very difficult biological questions so
what i'm going to do now is
spend a few minutes uh on cryos
first and then go on to talk about uh
glacious electrics and falcon 4 as well
so first
um as max trum said earlier uh the power
of four that survives g4 the ec
feg uh selectris uh and falcon four
um here what we did was uh around the
end of last year uh in december uh we
did this very nice
uh project this this collaboration was
initiated by promo hero and masahiro at
university of tokyo they were working
here on
streptavidin streptavidin is a very
small
52 kilo diet and protein it's very
flexible and very heterogeneous
um in 2019 hongweiwang
showed for the first time that they can
obtain a high resolution structure
going to 3.2 angstroms using
kaio em they use face plate at the time
to do this
about six months later uh another group
from princeton university young's group
pushed the resolution further to 2.6
angstroms without
using the faceplates um
end of last year tomohiro and masahiro
started
uh testing destructivity on their new
cryos
g4 and this is how it looked like so
this is the
grid on which they collected the data
these were the areas uh crit squares
where data was collected using uh g48
tokyo with
bioquantum k3 and from this
they obtained this uh beautiful
structure of the streptavidin going to
1.9 angstrom
this is already beautiful because this
this is the first
structure of a sub-100 kilo dalton
protein
going to sub 2 angstrom resolution
what we did next was even more exciting
they took this grid out from their
autoloader
in their lab in tokyo and they shipped
the same good
uh to netherlands to me and
what we did is uh using um
my microscope the cars g4 with the cfx
electrics
and falcon 4 i collected the data
in the similar uh goods quest near where
they had collected
the previous data set we tried and made
sure that we keep as many parameters as
possible constant
so in terms of pixel size is very
similar
in terms of those postcards similar uh
the defocus range
uh was kept similar uh it was a
different microscope
and uh has this uh and falcon 4
detector on it now and then
this is how the data looks like and this
is one of the
image of streptavidin it's low pass
filtered to about 20 angstroms so we can
clearly see all the particles here
and masahiro went ahead and processed uh
this
data and with similar amount of
particles
he produced this beautiful 1.7 angstrom
structure from the same grid now this is
this is
even more exciting that we can further
even after the grid was sitting in the
microscope for some time and was
transported um
publish a paper with lmb cambridge on
economic resolution structure of
apopheritin
as well as 1.7 angstrom structure of
human gaba receptor
there with the gaba receptor we saw that
at 1.7 angstrom
we can actually see hydrogen atoms um
so then the question was can we really
see the hydrogens even here with
uh 1.7 angstrom data um
this was done uh in collaboration with
uh people like lmb cambridge
uh especially kyotaro uh who works
in gary dose group um and indeed
we can actually see hydrogens in this
difference density here
all these little sticks that we see as
well as this green blobs
these are the densities for hydrogen
atoms
so not only we can push the resolution
of such a small protein to 1.7 angstrom
but now hydrogen atoms are also visible
um again showing how far this technology
has come in a very short period of time
so this is how we have been working so
far these are all the structures uh that
we have derived uh
using the kaios with selectris and
falcon 4
i already showed this 1.7 angstrom
streptavidin
last year i also showed you a hemoglobin
structure going through two angstroms
um steve gave a wonderful token showed
that even with
membrane proteins challenging membrane
products because these were very
flexible and very heterogeneous samples
uh we can push the resolution to 2.1
angstrom in case of this
3a ion channel um as well as
2.5 angstrom for the human potassium
channel
um again uh showcasing uh what we can do
nowadays
even with such small proteins and
cryo-electron microscopy
moving further uh we have this wonderful
collaboration with uh group of radhu
arashes crew
at mrc lmb as well in cambridge
where they are interested in looking at
structure-based uh drop design
raju is working on a human gaba receptor
gaba receptor is a 200 kilogram human
membrane protein
found in our brains uh it's acting as a
neurotransmitter
and it's responsible for our moods
depression uh it's also controlling
anxiety epilepsy insomnia then it has
been a target
for all these diseases now in addition
uh it's also
the drug target for things like sleeping
pills uh as well as uh anesthetics
so it's a very important receptor uh
it's a
asymmetric uh protein uh forms uh
chloride ion channel
and there are lots and lots of drugs
against uh this
channel one of the problem is uh this
channel could not be crystallized
uh at all after decades and decades of
work
now only way to get structures is by
cairo electron microscopy
so we looked at uh this sample and
again we can see this wonderful results
uh on a bottom mounted falcon 3
over 5 and 4 for this three different
drugs here
we can obtain uh 2.6 angstrom uh
structures where you can clearly see how
this drug is
bound uh and in case of two of these
uh drugs uh we managed to put them on to
selectris uh
falcon4 system uh in case of uh this
ro154513
uh which is a drug against alcohol uh
intoxication
uh we use exactly same grid uh which
went on to the bottom mounted falcon 4
first
and then went on to this electric falcon
4 and there is a
resolution was improved to 2.2 angstroms
and in case of zopiclone uh resolution
was
improved even further to 1.9 angstroms
we also looked at more uh drugs uh here
i'm showing you two more examples
uh oprah zolam which is uh drug against
uh anxiety
as well as panic disorder going to so
2.2 angstroms
and uh
going to uh 2.5 angstroms so now we have
like
this range of uh structures with all
these different drugs
bound within this gaba receptor and
nadu's team is
working on trying to understand the
function of this
and use this structure to do some
rational design
to make the drugs better to reduce the
side effect
to to to just improve its uh
capabilities
so this is what we can uh do uh with
kaio em with
kaios electrician 5.4 uh and
now what i would like to show you is uh
spend
few minutes trying to show what we have
been doing with this electrician falcon
4
also on a 200 kv glacious
uh system on the glaciers
uh so here we looked at proteosome
t20s this is a collaboration with a
group of huge and blitzco
at the max planck institute um on
unfiltered images with falcon 4 so like
kind of simulating a bottom mounted
system
um we can see particles when when we go
further away from focus so here about
0.8 micron d focus
we can start to see that yes particles
are present
but when we are closer to focus at 0.4
micron particles are hardly visible
as soon as we do the filtering uh with
the 10 ev slit
uh in this case the contrast improves
miraculously uh as you can see like very
close to focus as well all of these
particles are visible
and it's not just the contrast it's also
the signal to
noise that's improving in these images
um and since you have better signal
noise
particles are aligning better and this
leads to
higher resolution and this is exactly
what we observed here
with unfiltered particles uh we can get
about
2.34 angstrom structure um
when we use a 20 ev slit resolution is
further improved
by about 0.08 angstroms going to
2.26 and when
we use even narrow slits so now we are
removing all the noise from this plasmon
peak the resolution is further improved
to 2.14 angstrom
that's a massive difference going from
2.3 to 2.14
it also shows uh that the 20 uv slit
which is generally
used standardly in the field um
is it's good but with 10 ev you can get
even better resolution
now it's about 0.12 angstrom difference
between 20 and 10 avn about 0.08
angstrom difference between
um unfiltered versus
filtered uh imaging is this significant
if we look at the b factors uh then we
can see that yes there is there is
definitely
a big change going on from unfiltered
versus filtered
now all this data was collected on
exactly same grid
keeping as many parameters same uh as
we possibly can and it was also
collected consecutively
uh within uh one and a half days uh each
of this dataset took about 12 hours
uh it was running at about 200 250
movies per hour using
office so we try to keep as many things
same as possible
and still can obtain such high
resolution structures
we can also look at this uh by plotting
these b
vectors so here uh i'm plotting the b
factors in an exponential form
uh and what we can see um is
this green line belongs to the 10 e v
slit
uh 20 is the yellow line and the
unfiltered is red
and there is already a difference
between
this data sets if we were to
just uh take a point on this plot let's
say
two angstroms how many particles we
would need to reach two angstroms
then it becomes clear that uh with 10 ev
slit
we will need about 370 000 particles of
this type
not to these two angstroms if we use 10
db
now if we were to use a 20 eb slit
then we will need 1 million particles
to reach the same resolution and if we
don't use the slit at all if we use
bottom marker 5.4 without any filtering
then it would almost become impossible
for this data to reach uh
2.1 and some or two angstroms in this
case
um so indeed uh selectress or
energy filtering is helping you
tremendously even
uh at 200 kv as well
now this was all done uh with uh uh
proteosome 20 s which is a 700
kilodalton protein and has a d7 symmetry
next we wanted to see what happens if
you put something more uh challenging
and something smaller
so we try this on the gaba receptor
again
this is a homo pentametic form of gaba
it has a five-fold symmetry it's about
200 kilodalkin protein
and there we can see the difference is
even bigger
uh with unfiltered uh we can get 2.8
angstrom resolution
with 10 ev the resolution is improved to
2.4 angstrom just like a difference of
0.4 angstroms
and also with less number of particles
and again everything was done
using the same grid and same parameters
between the two sets so once again it
shows that filtering is really
helping uh push your resolution uh for
single particle analysis
now and at this resolution you can
already see your
bound drug molecules you can see all the
ordered
water molecules and can be used for
structure based
drug discovery now this is again this
has c5 symmetry
uh we wanted to see what happens if we
put even more challenging sample
with which doesn't have any symmetry um
for that uh we try to look at a gbcr
sample uh this is a collaboration with
the group of patrick saxton
at monash university as well as
in danao at tokyo university um
here we looked at uh gpcr sample glp
1r
another thing we did was we wanted to
also we wanted to like
push even further and see what happens
if we if we try and look at
sub-100 kilodigital proteins uh for this
uh we have another collaboration uh and
this collaboration is with
russell weber at the institute of cancer
research
in london where he is working on
this human cdk activating kinases to cdk
cycling
he sent us this sample now this sample
was
uh was very challenging because not only
it's
very flexible it has very high
heterogeneity but
also significant portion also has a
preferential orientation
uh however uh with um selectors and
falcon 4
on the glaciers we managed to find a
population
where there were all the orientations
present
and the structure was pushed to 2.5
angstroms
again showing that what we can do even
with the sub 100 kilo dalton
uh this protein is about 85 kilo dalton
line region there is also some flexible
bits uh
about uh 15 kilo dietan which which is
not visible in cryo edm
map because it's highly flexible so
also with the glaciers we have seen
a range of different structures uh
starting from apophetine
going to 1.7 angstrom the t20s
to 2.1 angstrom this 85 kilogram
cdk activating kinase to 2.5
angstroms uh we also looked at the
hemoglobin which is a 64 kiloton protein
which went to about uh 3.4 ish
uh angstrom uh resolution uh and in case
of
membrane proteins uh we look at the gaba
going to 2.4
and this gpcr sample going to 2.6
angstroms
with this i would like to thank all our
collaborators
for this wonderful support throughout
this work and also contributing to this
really nice samples and all their
expertise
and i would also like to thank you
everyone for listening to this webinar
thank you
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let me start with the the first question
so uh
i think i'll ask this one about what
resolution do you need for meaningful
interpretation of the drug discovery
sorry there was a lot of echo in the
beginning
could you repeat the question i just
heard my name no problem
uh what resolution do you need for
meaningful interpretation for drug
discovery
ah okay all right um so for it it
actually depends
on what question you are asking uh if
you just want to see whether
a ligand or your drug molecule is
present in in the binding pocket or note
then you don't need uh very high
resolutions
now one could get this information
already at around 3
3.5 angstroms in some cases even around
four angstroms
um if you want to start identifying
how this ligand is interacting with the
surrounding
environment uh then you need higher
resolution
now once you add 2.5 angstroms one
you start to see how how this binding is
happening what all the
uh hydrogen atoms are there you can
model uh
the ligand properly as well as all the
side chains
uh in your binding pocket uh and as soon
as
you start going higher and higher
resolution like going from 2.5 to about
2.2 angstroms you start to see all the
water molecules
uh and water molecules play very
important role especially when you want
to do like a structure based
drug discovery so i would say like
anywhere between two and two point five
angstroms uh you start getting more uh
accurate uh
details um from two point five to three
angstroms
uh you you can still see that how your
living is bound and how it's interacting
um with
a little less accuracy and from three
angstroms to four angstrom you can do
some predictions
there would you agree to you
with this
steve can you hear me ah yeah sorry just
didn't didn't catch that yeah i think
that's a that's
that's exactly what i would say as well
more more information
can learn more about the details of
these interactions but
if that makes sense okay
i think uh super in terms of
maybe resolution so how much do you
effect do you think the higher
magnification on the cryos had on the
final resolution of these maps
[Music]
up higher mark would you like to answer
yeah
i can at least say for in our case we
don't know we haven't done
a a comparison with the exact same pixel
size
on on different microscopes okay
and i think it it's very specific
question to your test two projects um
for you steve um have you tried
modulating different lipids for the
nanodisc
uh such as lipids unique to the brain or
other organs
yeah that's a great question we have not
yet we'd be very interested in doing
that
especially with the higher resolution
structures now where we can really make
out
what some of these interactions look
like
[Music]
okay thank you um so then i think
question for ab high was the strep
thevenin dinosaur also
collected with the um the coal sex or
only falcon 4 and selector
the strip private and data was collected
with the coal [ __ ]
selectors and falcon 4.
okay um and given the
same conditions you know sample grid
detector
what would be a typical difference in
the overall resolution range
expected observed from the data set
collected on a cryo
and glaciers
that uh depends uh we have done uh some
experiments
um with t20s and
gaba sample i showed you some t20s data
now with uh selectris uh and falcon 4
we can achieve this 2.1 angstroms on the
glaciers
um same sample if it was not exactly the
same grid it was a different
grid but same sample same kind of ice
thickness
uh when collected uh on the cryos we can
also
give us with a bottom market camera
first we can also
achieve um two 2.1 angstrom
however with less number of particles i
think it was
almost half the number of particles
there
uh in case of uh gaba receptor now
where there is a lower symmetry
some more flexibility some more
challenges uh there the difference
starts to
become uh slightly bigger uh on the
glaciers with electrics we get 2.4
angstroms
on the cryos with the bottom mounted
falcon 4
uh we get to two angstroms uh and cryos
with electricity and falcon 4
uh we push it to 1.7 angstroms uh in
case of a symmetric
uh form of gaba
okay thanks um maybe just a quick
follow-up question
um related to a few questions about the
electrics so have you tested the benefit
of
the selectors on samples with thicker
ice or tilted samples when the
resolution is usually limited
i'm not not really like a direct
side-by-side comparison where
i look at the same sample on a thick and
thin ice but in principle
when you have a thicker sample or you
have more inelastic scattering
uh filtering should help even more
but it is a very good question and and
we should we should do some uh
experiments on this in theory uh yes
uh it should help and this is all the
whole basis of tomography
that thicker sample filtering is going
to help you much more
okay um so we also have a few questions
about the
the nano disks so um with the nano disk
results
without the proteins were they
president's solution
you can see that's for you oh with yeah
when we
purify um anatous typically there's um
some portion of the sample that are
empty nana discs that are
going to be frozen along with the target
and nanodisks
and we just need to remove those
computationally
as we as we process data
okay and and then maybe same question um
the concentrations of the
nano dix were they too high or
um i think they work quite well so
that's that's actually how
they do look high they you know we like
to have the particles
tiled um quite closely on the grids we
find that it
um gives us thinner ice and
makes makes processing easier actually
so that's that's about where we like
them to be
um in those two cases they're
between one and two migs per mill for
the 3a project
and the test 2 project um but that's
quite sample dependent um
what concentration we need to go to to
have distribution that looks similar to
what you saw on the slides today
okay great thanks well based on your
experience uh what
are the suitable detergents from
membrane protein cryo-em grids
and how did you overcome the
difficulties caused by the detergent
maybe steven if you want to answer that
first
sure are you trying to um
prefer to be in nanodisks and so that's
how we avoid the problem but abe
probably has
more experience with other detergents uh
indeed i mean uh this is this is why we
want to move everything towards
nano disks uh it was the same with gaba
as well all the kabbalah that i showed
the sample was within the nano disks
when when radu's group uh tried uh
in early days with detergents uh they
saw lots of differences
uh in in how this channel was uh
behaving because the channel is very
dynamic uh in most cases the channel was
found to be collapsed so yeah
generally if you can you should move
away from detergent try to go
towards nanodisk with lipids from
similar environments if possible but
but if there is no other option uh you
can always try
uh with uh ddm uh for example
that's the first detergent that i have
been trying
um now there are even better detergents
for example uh has been shown to work
very well
uh with membrane proteins um
and there are also several literature
screens um already available which you
could try
but again this is i would say the same
thing that if you can use
nano disks i would go with analysis
instead of going through the detergent
route
okay all right thanks maybe
along those same lines um the question
was asked like for the resolution
improvement of these cases how much can
you attribute
of hardware you know and how much
distribution protein preparation
specific conditions
uh the sample prep is always the main
thing
um in terms of hardware um
with using uh standard samples
such as apple creating for example now
we can test our hardware very well
and last year we showed that using the
same system
uh this car is g4 with uh exelectors and
falcon
4 when we use uh epiphyte in sample
we could really get to the atomic
resolution and we could get 1.2 angstrom
with the best
uh factors uh ever um so we know that
yes hardware is good
uh now you have we have to work towards
optimizing
uh the samples and it happens in a few
things like you need to have like
optimized uh
grades first um and there are a lot lots
and lots of uh
improvements happening on the great side
uh more recently
we saw this wonderful date from this
russo
now also uh chris and laurie a few years
ago showed that the bluegrass
are much better and we also see the same
thing that
do uh behave better in terms of this
motion
compared to the carbon grids so that's
one thing
uh second thing uh is your eyes quality
of course thinner eyes the better but
at some stage you start having problems
with a water interface if you try and
do much thinner eyes or even light
starts melting in some cases
um and then also sample sample has to be
if if we put a very flexible or very
heterogeneous sample
uh then then we are not going to get uh
very high resolutions
uh so again some biochemistry uh helps
there
okay thanks so you started talking about
the hardware
i'll switch there for this question um
will the ec feg
also be available for retrofit retrofit
possibilities on existing cryos
microscopes
uh mark yes indeed the case
so if you have a cries of the generation
g3 or g3i
and you were a great instrument to
windows 10
then you can indeed have the colfax
retrofitted onto those
instruments
and of course in addition to the price
default of course can always be equipped
also as a retrofit later on in the field
if you decide to add on a call back
later on
okay um you also talked about the
flashing interval that is
fully integrated into epu and tomo
software but when is such a flashing
procedure triggered and
what is the interval between the
flashing generally
mark i think yeah yeah so typically
actually when the beam current drops 10
then you get actually a trigger of a
flashing procedure in the the nature
paper of
uh of nakanodal we have actually
reported that
uh such intervals is roughly eight hours
between the flashes but we have also
seen on our internal instruments that we
can easily reach
intervals which are more than 10 hours
so really actually long time
okay thanks so i think this will be our
our last question
um this one will be i think for steve
was there a difference in the data
processing of the small proteins with
the cryos data
was it difficult to process the data for
such small proteins
yes good question um they were difficult
data sets to process
um that's that's for sure i think
that you know it is a testament to how
i'm talented david and bauman in my lab
who processed this data and chris hall
um are that they got these things to
work we
did not though see you know if anything
it was it was maybe a little bit easier
to process data
collected with the selectrus
on obvious microscope than it was to
process data from
the arctica but both use similar
pipelines
and you can kind of check out the
details in the in the papers in the
preprint
and those um use
a kind of approach that we found to be
um
pretty robust for a few projects
of similar size targets
okay great so i think with that i want
to thank you again
um steve mark and ab high for your time
today and for
answering questions as well as you're
sharing your important research
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for your interesting questions uh
questions unfortunately that we didn't
have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
if you are a current customer and would
like more information such as a data
sheet please contact your account
manager
if you don't know who that is please
contact us
in the forms and the links provided in
the resource window
in the lab routes module
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you
with an email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues that may
have missed today's live event
please join us again on may 19 for our
next webinar on
our next thermo fisher electron
microscopy monthly
series on lab roots you'll be hearing
about our new capabilities for
correlative microscopy and our
integrated light fluorescence microscope
that is part of our electron
cryotomography workflow
uh the registration is open so again
thanks again to our speakers thanks for
all for joining us
until next time goodbye